En el video anterior hablamos sobre la
proporcionalidad y la razón entre cantidades,
y vimos algunos ejemplos. En este video vamos a
hablar de otra técnica para resolver problemas de
proporcionalidad: la regla de tres simple. Este
método consiste en encontrar un cuarto valor en
una proporción cuando ya se conocen tres. Te darás
cuenta que la regla de tres simple es una igualdad
de razones: a / b = c / d, que nos ayuda a
encontrar la magnitud desconocida a partir de una
razón descrita. Si te fijas bien, podrás ver que
es la letra d la que buscamos. La regla de tres
simple se utiliza en problemas de proporcionalidad
directa, es decir, cuando las magnitudes se mueven
en la misma dirección: si una aumenta, la otra
también; así como en problemas de proporcionalidad
inversa: cuando las magnitudes se mueven en
dirección contraria una aumenta y la otra
disminuye. Comencemos con el ejemplo del video
anterior: si con 126 dólares se pueden comprar
6 pantalones, ¿cuánto se pagará por la compra
de 9 pantalones? Estamos ante un problema de
proporcionalidad directa: el costo de 9 pantalones
tiene que ser mayor que el costo de 6 pantalones,
y el incremento del costo será proporcional;
entonces 6 → 126 como 9 → x. El procedimiento
para calcular x es el siguiente: multiplicamos 9 *
126 = 1134, y este resultado lo dividimos entre 6:
nos da 189 dólares. Entonces, comprar 9 pantalones
costará 189 dólares. Sólo hemos igualado nuestras
razones: 126 / 6 = x / 9; despejamos x: 126 / 6
= 21, el 9 que divide pasa del otro lado de la
igualdad multiplicando: 9 * 21 = 189. Veamos otro
problema. Si 20 obreros hacen una obra en 18 días,
¿cuántos obreros serán necesarios para realizarla
en 30 días? Nuevamente, primero observamos nuestra
razón: 20 obreros realizan la obra en 18 días:
20 obreros es a 18 días; y después utilizaremos
el método de reducción a la unidad para buscar el
valor de la unidad, en este caso el número de días
que tardaría un solo obrero en terminar la obra,
lo que equivaldría al total de lo que hacen 18
días los 20 obreros, por lo que nuestra operación
será la siguiente: 1 obrero → 18 días * 20 obreros
= 360 días: esto es lo que tardaría un solo obrero
en terminar. Para obtener el número de obreros que
necesitamos para realizar la obra en 30 días,
dividamos el valor de la unidad, es decir,
lo que tarda un obrero en finalizar la obra: 360
días entre los 30 días en los que queremos que se
terminen: 360 / 30, lo que nos da un resultado
de 12 obreros. Esto también lo podemos obtener
mediante la regla de tres simple: 18 días →
20 obreros, 30 días → x obreros. En este caso,
la razón proporcional de las variables es inversa
porque a mayor número de obreros menos días de
obra, entonces los valores se cambian de posición
y ahora tenemos: 30 días → 20 obreros, 18 días → x
obreros. Ya que cambiamos los valores, te invito
a que pausa el video y realices la regla de tres
como lo hicimos anteriormente. Ahora hagámoslo
juntos, obtengamos el valor de x multiplicando
18 * 20, esto es igual a 360, y el resultado lo
dividimos entre 30, igual a 12 obreros. Recuerda
que sólo hemos igualado nuestras razones 20 / 30
= x / 18. Despejamos x: el 18 que divide pasa del
otro lado de la igualdad multiplicando: 20 / 30 *
18 = x, 20 * 18 nos da 360, entre 30 es igual a x,
360 / 30 = 12. También hay ocasiones en donde los
problemas involucran tres diferentes magnitudes:
a → b y → c; d → e y → f, y estas magnitudes
presentan relaciones directas e inversas al
mismo tiempo, esto se conoce como regla de tres
compuesta. Como vimos antes al igualar nuestras
razones, podremos encontrar un valor incógnito,
que podríamos suponer cf: a → b → c = d → e → y a
nuestra incógnita. Veamos un ejemplo. Si 30
carpinteros fabrican 10 armarios en 15 días,
¿cuántos días tardarán 45 carpinteros para
hacer 12 armarios iguales? Primero debemos
encontrar las relaciones de proporcionalidad
respecto a nuestra variable incógnita: días;
veremos que hay una relación directa y otra
inversa. La primera relación, armarios a días,
es directamente proporcional porque para hacer
más armarios se necesitan más días; la segunda
relación, carpinteros a días, pues podemos deducir
que a mayor cantidad de carpinteros necesitaremos
menos días. Tenemos esta información: 10 → 30
→ 15, 12 → 45 → x. Hagamos el siguiente cuadro:
ahora podemos usar la regla de tres compuesta a
través de la fórmula que ya conocemos, es decir,
igualando las razones. Comenzamos con nuestra
primera razón, iniciemos con nuestra variable
incógnita, días. Cuando es una relación directa
dividimos, entonces 15 días / 10 armarios,
y multiplicamos cuando la relación es inversa,
entonces 15 / 10 * 30 carpinteros. Analiza que
nuestra razón ya no se ve como una división debido
a que ahora hemos involucrado más magnitudes.
Siguiendo el mismo procedimiento en nuestra
segunda razón, tenemos: x días / 12 armarios * 45
carpinteros. Igualamos nuestras razones: a → b →
c = d → e → x, 15 / 10 * 30 = x / 12 * 45. Ahora
resolvamos nuestra ecuación: 15 * 30 nos da 450
entre 10; del otro lado: x * 45 nos da 45 x / 12,
450 / 10 es 45; despejamos nuestra x: el 45
multiplica y divide, por lo que podemos hacerlo
1 y eliminarlo de nuestra ecuación. Finalmente,
tenemos 12 = x, 45 carpinteros tardarán 12 días
para hacer 12 armarios. Lo que hemos hecho aquí
es encontrar razones proporcionales que pueden ser
directas, es decir, cuando una magnitud aumenta
la otra magnitud aumenta, o pueden ser inversas
cuando una magnitud aumenta la otra magnitud
disminuye, y a partir de ellas hemos encontrado
respuestas a preguntas que implican el uso de la
regla de tres simple cuando tenemos dos razones
de proporcionalidad, o la regla de tres compuesta
cuando tenemos tres razones de proporcionalidad.